[Music]
imagine if you could connect your brain
to the Internet you wouldn't need to
type into a search engine you could just
think your query and download the
relevant knowledge directly into your
mind such a world would involve the
biggest single upgrade in human
intelligence since our species evolved
seamless brain computer interfaces are a
long way off but the melding of minds
with machines is already underway the
implant goes directly into the motor
control area of the brain it's that
neuro technology that we've been
developing for years and it's designed
to help restore replaced function or
enhance independence for people who are
paralyzed in a pioneering clinical trial
at Brown University volunteers have been
given brain implants that allow them to
control devices using thought alone to
date this academic venture this pilot
clinical trial that we call brain gay
has enrolled 13 participants and each of
those has had this sensor placed into
the motor cortex and each of them has
been able to control cursor movement on
a screen some of them have even been
able to control prosthetic limb or a
robotic limb moving through space to
reach and grab objects
the sensors detect the neural signals
associated with the intent to move and
they're decoded by a computer in
real-time
we're tapping into the native a part of
the brain that controls movement
naturally so simply by imagining
intuitive movements participants can
immediately control a robotic device the
technology could transform the lives of
people with disabilities but it could go
further enhancing the abilities of the
entire human race one problem is that
current technology can only record the
activity of a couple of hundred neurons
our minds are generated by a bewildering
network of 85 billion neurons listening
to them all in real time has proved an
impossible challenge for neuro
scientists but in 2013 their research
gained powerful backing there's this
enormous mystery waiting to be unlocked
and the brain initiative will change
that by giving scientists the tools they
need to get a dynamic picture of the
brain in action and better understand
how we think and how we learn and how we
remember the brain initiative is a six
billion dollar fund to find new ways to
map the activity of an entire brain
leading neuroscientist professor Rafael
used-- was at the front of the queue for
funding the goal of the brain ative is
precise and to build methods to read and
manipulate the activity of neural
circuits so that we can eventually help
patients that have mental or neuro call
diseases in 2017 professor uses team
announced that they had successfully
recorded the activity from every neuron
of an animal albeit a very simple one a
tiny freshwater relative of the
jellyfish called a Hydra in a way you
could argue that we're trying to read
the hydras mind because we can measure
the activity of every neuron in Hydra
while the Hydra is behaving
and once you've learned to read neural
code you can learn to write it - can we
input thoughts into a Hydra can we write
a patterns of activity and change the
behavior of the animal we're trying to
do this in Hydra and we're trying to do
this in mice we can imagine that you
could do this with humans in the future
the human brain is vastly more complex
than the Hydra and converting the
electrochemical signals of the mind into
the digital language of machines remains
a huge technological challenge but
history has shown that where there's a
will and plenty of money there's a way
to achieve making neuroscience the new
rocket science we're not speaking
publicly currently about what we're
billing we want I'm tech entrepreneurs
are turning their minds and their money
to developing brain machine interfaces
Brian Johnson founded kernel a neural
interface startup with a hundred million
dollars of his own money everyone's
trying to find how to go from where
right now in the next thing jump to what
we're going to be and in building kernel
my objective is to radically improve
humans in every imaginable and
unimaginable way Brian Johnson is not
alone in this dream Elon Musk's latest
company neural Inc aims to enhance
humans by connecting them to computers
DARPA the research and development arm
of the American military is also at the
forefront of this technology
brain-computer interfaces are coming but
are we ready I think every day of the
potential dangers of building technology
without thinking carefully about the
consequence of this technology for
society if we allow the Internet into
our minds what's to stop it reading the
thoughts we'd rather keep private we're
not talking about data privacy this is
much worse we're talking about the
contents of your mind and if we discover
how to enhance our intelligence who gets
to go first you need to ensure as a
society that there is equitable access
to this technology so that it doesn't
end up in the hands of a privileged view
it's vital that ethical considerations
keep pace with advancing technology
melding our minds with machines could
radically transform society but some
argue that the transformation is already
underway and if we don't use machines to
improve ourselves we risk being left
behind humans are the most intelligent
species on this earth we are now giving
birth to a new form of intelligence in
the form of AI at what point do we begin
feeling uncomfortable with the Delta
between our own improvement and that of
our machines AI the thing we need to
controvert very seriously for me it's
the best thing you could ever happen to
us and it's critical that we try to
co-evolved with this unbelievable
powerful form of intelligence that we're
now building the matrix is not imminent
but enough research is now being done on
brain computer interfaces that it's time
to think hard about their potential
implications if superhuman intelligence
is created in the future humanity could
reap huge benefits as long as it's
handled with care